Marie is an RA Milliken professor
emeritus at Caltech Distinguished Fellow
and one of the founders of the Santa Fe
Institute please join me in welcoming
him as he introduces tonight's speaker
in this year's series named after my old
friend Stan Lum if he were alive I'm
sure he would be proud to be associated
with our lecturer J Doan farmer and I'm
delighted to have this opportunity to
express in public my admiration of dawn
as a scientist and as a person for this
introduction however the authorities at
our Institute tried to find another icon
like the one that introduced tho and
last night but they failed one of our
rare technical failures and so they were
forced to call on me even though I have
great trouble morphing into an ape or
into W or a mixture of the two
you know that Dolan and his colleagues
had a great deal of success at the
prediction company using past
fluctuations in financial markets to
make probabilistic predictions of future
fluctuations and many prominent people
said of course that that couldn't be
done eventually Dolan decided that he
could afford to embrace academic life
and he joined us as a research professor
to my great delight one subject he's
studying at the Santa Fe Institute along
with a number of bright associates is
why investors behavior allowed the
prediction company to make money and
that's just part of a very general
interest in mathematical regularities in
human affairs that Dolan and I share and
we we both want to understand some of
these regularities and answer some
questions about them such as how robust
are they how much do they constrain the
future how much do they limit the
effects of public policy decisions and
of course many of you are familiar with
a number of these regularities
really quite mysterious why does Moore's
law hold which says that the amount of
information on the computer chip doubles
every half hour or whatever it is I mean
how was Gordon able to predict that
years ago and why is it still true
you know it's constant relative rate of
increase it's claimed that for example
in France the maximum speed of human
transport has gone up by a constant
percentage for a constant percentage per
unit time for two centuries through
changes from foot to horse to carriage
to railroad to car to plane to jet plane
and so on very bizarre and of course
these Exponential's eventually have to
level off and then they become s curves
but there's a very simple s-curve the
so-called logistic curve that explains
enormous numbers of things the describes
I should say enormous numbers of things
like cumulative casualties in a war or
plague cumulative scientific output
cumulative musical output so on and so
forth all very fascinating doens
interesting this kind of thing goes back
quite a long time he was at the Center
for nonlinear Studies at the Los Alamos
lab si nos around the time when the
Institute was really getting started
properly and he and his friends
organized at that time a wonderful
meeting at the lab on evolution learning
and games and that meeting played a very
important part in the development of SFI
I think it fitted in perfectly with what
we were hoping to accomplish and some of
the participants became regular visitors
and others became occasional visitors to
the Institute to our great benefit no
one is the same colorful character that
he was at that time almost 15 years ago
despite the absence now of the trademark
red suspenders
they're still there in a way even though
you can't see them anymore the last
night we saw and heard dawn engaged in
an argument with a bogus creationist /
intelligent design person and he
appeared to lose the argument actually I
was rather unhappy about that but that's
only because he was just being his kind
polite itself and tonight I'm sure you
will see him triumph over every
adversity thank you
well thanks Marie for a very kind
introduction and thanks to all of you
for actually making it out here for a
second second time in a row I uh and
exhausted you so much last night that no
one would have the energy to show up so
I appreciate you all being here let me
also say at one point last night pardon
check the mute just a second
mute on its off powers on should be live
you on okay it is on no all right mute
on that's kind of a confusing
terminology anyway okay so you see if
I'm my flight at dancers working oh did
work something work there's a demon back
there that you know I don't think this
is what did I do that or did you do that
alright so I just I I think most of you
were probably here last night and so I
already explained why I'm using this
title so I don't think I'm gonna do that
again but okay so I just want to review
what we did last night briefly this was
my outline I went over entropy
information and statistical mechanics
the history of the mechanistic view what
a machine was the need for simpler copy
machines talked about biological versus
human technology and the amazing growth
that human population has had now I was
urged to recapitulate the main points
because I do have a tendency to go very
fast and that's another reason why
people should shout out if I start being
unclear because I go faster and faster
like the human population okay so first
point is why is the world propagated
with functional structures so the I
guess the phrase I made up for this is
propagation implies prevalence that is
if if there are things out there that
propagate those things will become
prevalent and become the most common
things and and those things are the
machines the machines that are able to
store and harness information in order
to do things that make them better able
to propagate then just then other things
now I want to emphasize that I my view
on this as we aren't reducing the
universe to just mechanics rather that
through processes of self-organization
and dynamics machines are capable of far
more than previously thought and to read
a quote from CH Waddington vitalism
amounted to the assertion that living
things did not behave as though they
were nothing but mechanisms constructed
of mere material components but this
supreme presupposes that one knows what
mere material components are and what
kind of mechanisms they can be built of
and so I'll let you go it's a little
it's actually kind of a tricky because
there's a double negative in there which
I always hate but but nonetheless I
think it it gets across that idea very
nicely if I could go back a slide ok
biological life human artifacts and
human societies all evolved and that
relationship is becoming increasingly
intimate which was the main point of the
last part of my talk
ok now rolling forward ok this is the
outline for tonight's talk I'm going to
begin by trying to tie the talk in
weather with the room try to talk to
that try to tie this this talk in with
the up to the other themes of the talk I
have to admit I'm being a little
self-indulgent here I'm totally wedging
prediction prediction in here because
it's something I've been so involved in
but
okay and I'm going to give a review of
different methods of prediction and some
of my own in his my own history and
involvement in these different methods
of prediction finally we're not funny
I'm also going to discuss a some recent
research over the last year at SFI which
has been very you know excuse me
don't don't change that okay I'm going
to give some of my own experience in or
the sorry some of the work we've been
doing at SFI over the last year which
has produced a market model that's
that's already had some remarkable
success and so I'll share that with you
it fits in as as the title describes
it's a very mechanistic model and it
uses principles that are very different
from standard economics then we're going
to talk about what's maybe conceptually
the more interesting aspect of this how
prediction can make reality more
subjective and self-fulfilling versus
self-defeating prophecies and how the
ability to predict interacts and changes
the world and and and makes it more
complicated as as evidenced by things
like market manias and what are what I
would call other social schizophrenias
so the final lecture just just as a plug
is to put some of this together at a
more conceptual level talk about purpose
what makes people happy the debate on
progress the euro of time and a little
bit not too much about morality and
cooperation and and using my background
and prediction to at least make some
predictions about the future though if I
were really smart I wouldn't stick my
neck out and do that because that's a
notoriously unsuccessful enterprise
anyway so on to the next next slide here
so now first I want to try and tie this
in with the main theme of the whole
series which is that I see prediction as
the computational component of any kind
of purposeful behavior
purposeful behavior consists of three
parts sensing you have to know what's
going on in the world prediction you
have to be able to predict what's going
to happen next in action action is taken
in order to take advantage of the
prediction and and purposeful behavior
and therefore prediction exists in the
world because they're useful for
propagation so even when you have
something as simple as say a bacteria
swimming in a chemical gradient that
bacteria is making predictions about the
world in order to decide which way to
swim so that the bacteria can eat more
than it would if it's went in the wrong
direction all right now let me let me
just mention that this sensation
prediction action is something that's
often studied in in the guise of control
theory a modern engineering discipline
that grew out of cybernetics which was
was in a sense an earlier incarnation of
what's now called complex system ok so
next slide oh yeah I'm going to talk
about methods of prediction in
particular I'm gonna argue that there
are really three different aspects that
determine the way ones that one goes
about building a predictive model one
question is relates to how the model is
constructed and in physics we like to
construct models that are built out of
what we call first principles we we
observe the world we create a model of
the world that's that's based on some
deeper understanding of what what
happens and as say Newton's laws in
physics and then we use that model to
make predictions about the world but
there's an alternative approach which is
empirical modeling that I'll go I'll go
over I realize I have slides on you
today so I shouldn't explain too much
detail now the other question is what is
the model predict that is some models
predict things going forward in time
other models actually just predict
contemporaneous things they predict
things about the relation of things that
are that are present and those models
tend have very different flavors and
finally two of the basic models that we
use are on one hand deterministic models
and on the other hand random process
models so you know I should mention this
is not this is how scientists do it it's
not the only way it's done here I'll
give you an
iseman I actually received in the mail
for the astrological prediction of stock
prices you know 100 our great database
this doesn't fit into my paradigm as far
as I can tell
next slide another example there's an
example of prediction based on
numerology and I don't I've never really
understood this though the guy was
actually nice enough to send me his book
where all these pictures are contained
it's actually a fairly well-respected
financial analyst a lot of people follow
so here on one and he shows prices and
how he believes they're built out of
this magic sequence of numbers called a
Fibonacci sequence and on the other hand
he argues that the same sequence can
explain why Frankenstein was popular in
this era and Mary Poppins appeared up
here and we went back to splatter movies
down here and so on anyway I'm also this
doesn't quite seem to fit into my
paradigm either though it is a dynamical
prediction now so back to these three
dichotomies the first economy is how is
the model constructed I already went
through this let me just to construct a
first principles model you have to have
a fairly high degree of sophistication I
would I would say that roughly speaking
as far as we know people and and people
are just about the only things capable
of doing this at this point now the
other alternative is what I'm going to
call an empirical model is where you
build a model empirically by just
fitting historical data for simple
organisms like a bacteria swimming in a
gradient there's some hardwired model
that's been tuned up by evolutions it's
wired in by genetics the bacterium just
knows what to do for more complex
organisms like say dogs there may be
further tuning by experience there's
some free parameters in this model that
gets set by play and and simply by
interacting the world so they get tuned
up next slide now so the other question
is what is the model predict on one end
we have dynamical systems models which
predict the future based on the past and
our fundamental anything like say
celestial mechanics
in fact their fundamental to just
anything we're predicting the future in
science there are contemporaneous models
that relate one property of the world to
another at the same time and this might
not sound so interesting but it can be
very useful in simplifying our
description of the world and make sure
that we really understand what we're
doing
finally there's what I might call the
modeling paradigm on one hand we have
the deterministic model where the world
is described by a single point state
space that completely determines the
future and the rule that does this is
called a dynamical system I'll say what
I mean by a state space in just a minute
or random models where the evolution of
future States is not necessarily
determined by present States in there's
a continuum between these models which
is the one we more realistically
typically work in okay so the idea to a
dynamical prediction is a state space
the state is a list of numbers that
gives the information needed to
determine the future so if you have n
such numbers it's often useful to think
of them as defining an N dimensional
state space so for example if you're
thinking about say a mass on a spring
the position and velocity of the spring
from Newton's laws are sufficient to
determine the future motion now to think
about that we think about two axes one
that has the position and one that has
the velocity this is a trick that goes
back to Galileo I discovered in my
research here and and it's sometimes
hard for people to get used to because
we call it a state space it's not like
real space in three dimensions it's an
imaginary space that involves abstract
quantities but those the axes of that
space behave from a mathematical point
of view just like real space that we're
used to so so physicists or anybody who
does dynamical system just talks about
this all the time now okay so next slide
now as an example how does a bacteria
make this decision about which way to
swim in the gradient
well the bacteria must somehow predict
the concentration in fact the rate of
change of concentrations of the bacteria
senses the concentration of the point
swims around senses it again if it
increased it goes
I must be swimming up the gradient and
so isn't is then tends to swim in that
same direction if on the other hand the
bacterium discovers the concentration is
decreased the bacteria says up
something's wrong and it goes into the
tumble mode and when it discovers that
the bacteria the concentration really
isn't changing it tends to go in to eat
mode okay so in this case the state
space it's very simple it's just a
number it's the rate of change of the
concentration that's what the bacterium
needs to know to know which way to swim
now actually a three-dimensional world
it's really three numbers because there
are three possible directions that that
concentration is increasing so the
bacteria actually ideally wants the
sentence a vector but probably at any
given at any given stage of the swim the
bacteria is just sensing the
concentration along that direction okay
we are not going to have the dynamical
systems movie for various reasons it's
it's very old movie anyway so what that
you know I had a nostalgic value for me
but anyway time limits I'm gonna try by
the way much harder to try and finish on
time tonight I realized at the end I
took at least an hour and a half so I
apologize I am going to try and finish
earlier now an important aspect about
the world that I played a role in and
illuminating is the fact that there are
limits to prediction they come from the
fact that when we go into the state
space and we think about the dynamical
systems the rules that actually move
points around in state space those rules
even from fairly simple equations can
can be complicated they could be
complicated in the sense that they're if
stretching and folding and I'll show you
a picture in a minute of how that
happens they can produce behavior that
looks random even though it's in a
purely deterministic setting and we're
small uncertainties in initial
measurements are amplified limiting
predictability so next slide now this is
put look better than I can and I'll get
some water while you guys read ahead
why Punk arrayed who interestingly
realized this back in the in the early
1900s and and and we was studying
something called a three body problem
the problem with through three when you
have the Sun and say say two planets in
the solar system and he discovered that
that basically that chaos could happen
in there now interestingly this was
somewhat lost from the mainstream
science for for almost seventy years and
or maybe more than seventy years so let
me know that you've read it I'll read it
again just just so you you get the whole
impact here a very small cause which
escapes our notice determines a
considerable effect that we cannot fail
to see and then we say that the effect
is due to chance if we knew exactly the
laws of nature in the situation of the
universe at the initial moment we could
predict exactly the situation of that
same universe at a succeeding moment but
even if it were the case that the
natural laws had no longer any secret
for us we could still only know the
initial situation approximately if that
enabled us to predict the succeeding
situation with the same approximation
that is all we require and we should say
that the phenomenon had been predicted
that it is governed by laws but it is
not always so it may happen that small
differences in initial conditions
produce very great ones in the final
phenomenon a small error in the former
will produce an enormous error in the
latter prediction becomes impossible and
we have the fortuitous phenomenon so to
go to the next slide we're now going to
see I hope a movie of plunk array and
we're going to see a map
imagine plunk arrays picture pasted on
the plane and now what we're going to
see is that we're going to take the
plane and we're gonna stretch it out and
in fact what we stretch out we stretch
it out and then fold it back in you can
see how those pieces are coming back in
and we're seeing successive images of
plonker a as he gets stretched and then
reinserted and stretched and reinserted
and stretched and reinserted and so if
we keep running that forward we
eventually just end up with a gray
background so what we've just seen is a
mixing machine
take mr. Parker a and turned him into
mush and now we're seeing that run
backwards okay so um all right
so Marcus maybe just roll it slowly one
more time so if you oh no you're okay
all right roll it forward okay so we see
him getting stretched we see new images
of reappear because they're being
reinserted and they get more and more
stretched he gets more and more
elongated and so this is the kind of
thing that's going on in state space
somewhere whenever chaos is going on now
typically it's not just reinsertion like
this where you just cut it and stick it
back in but rather folding gets
stretched out folded back stretched out
and fold it back like when you're
kneading bread dough now I'm also going
to bravely try to do a live
demonstration here I I'm had a feeling
it's unlikely to work but we'll see all
right can we i blank that there white it
doesn't really matter we'll be able to
see it so now what I have here it's
blocked so you can't see it but it's
it's a pendulum there's just a pendulum
and a few magnets down underneath the
pendulum is magnetic so when I swing the
pendulum it interacts with the magnetic
fields and what I'm going to try and do
is get the pendulum to take more or less
the same motion on successive trials so
I'll pull the Bob out here and let it go
you can see it does something kind of
irregular and in this case it stops in
the middle now when I'm lucky I'll
actually get it to stop on one of these
side nuggets now I'm going to try and do
the very same thing
let me try it again
and see every time I do this it takes a
somewhat different reject me now by okay
there we get a more erratic orbit now I
did actually pull it off to the side but
but let me try that same one again oops
oh you can tell I swung it a bit too
hard there
now we're getting a nice interesting
orbit though and look we actually get it
to stick to that guy now now one more
time I'll try and do the same thing and
we'll see if it sticks to the same place
or it ends up does the same thing okay I
got it in kind of a regular mode up
knocked out of it
no it's doing more erratic orbit where
is it gonna end up nobody knows I don't
know anyway oh okay so yeah good idea I
should just quit right now
okay so point I want to make here is
that I'm chaos is a double-edged sword
that is on one hand it changed a lot of
things because of different people where
they were looking at random phenomena
said wait a minute
maybe it's not just maybe it's not just
lots and lots of complicated things
interacting maybe it's actually pretty
simple and there's some pattern there
that we can find on the other hand one
of the things that I and Johnson or
bitch Jim Crutchfield Bruce McNamara
Pharisees were involved in showing is
that actually chaos is it's not just a
negative thing that makes things harder
for us in some way during the background
of the world where we thought lots of
things were random processes some things
that looked really complex actually
become much more simple on the
short-term so systems that were
otherwise believed to be random become
predictable in the short term and these
are some examples of some of the systems
that we worked on simple mechanical
oscillator we just demonstrated that
where at least the methods for
prediction that we came
they were empirical methods for
prediction seem to produce better
predictions so on slide this is the one
that I actually got my teeth on here
this is the rolling ball on a circular
track with a counter spinning inside
track and some deflectors and an
obstacles sort of in between the final
resting place the game of roulette which
is a classical physics problem that new
who could have solved it's it's it's
lots measuring position of velocity at a
given point in time determines the
future motion that is if you know the
forces it did take us know four to six
months to actually figure out what the
forces were and convince ourselves to
get it right wind resistance is the main
one the equation of motion looks kind of
like this when you boil it down and you
write out Newton's laws and simplify it
the rate of change of the velocity of
the ball is some constant times the
velocity squared as I mentioned last
night this is the very same equation the
human population follows except the ball
is slowing down whereas the human
population is speeding up there's also
some complications due to tilt and
motion the ball on the tray this turned
out to be very important it took us four
years to realize this was so important
no I should say it is chaotic but a
perfect trap isn't chaotic but
prediction is difficult because of the
circularity of the wheel you know you're
not you're not just predicting something
they're just moving in a line it's
moving around around a circle and you
care about the position within that
circle so it's kind of like taking two
numbers of dividing one number by
another number if you change the number
you're dividing by it can have a big
effect on the remainder because the the
final position is is the remainder in
this case the imperfections in the track
and ball created turbulence that is the
ball actually moves chaotically just
because the the track isn't perfect and
it gets jostle around and there's
bouncing on cups but this is all details
next slide now this is the
machine that we use to make the
prediction another view of the machine
out of the shoe with a battery pack the
piece of double PC boards and wax in
between this is just illustrating that
the frictions the way in which the
predictions work or that they did work
that is we would divide the wheel up
into eight parts and look at the numbers
in that part which number we expected
compare the prediction to the actual and
so if it landed on the exact octant we
predicted we've marked here if it landed
minus 2 or minus 3 away we've mark here
and you can see that you do a lot better
actually you can also see the parameters
are a bit off the parameters would be
able to adjusting here but basically the
ball was very unlikely to land over here
and very likely to land here
illustrating that work
this was our family of computers they
all have names etc because it's a shag
carpet of our Las Vegas tacoma these are
the copy machines this is Norman Packard
and you might recognize the other guy
this is illustrating the kind of
technology we were using at the time and
and the way in which the copy machine
process work this is this is a typical
trip Norma and I would spend the entire
time fixing computers and everybody else
would sit and wait and ask why they
weren't ready to go yet next slide so
this my real light experience
illustrated a couple things what is it
it did introduce the idea of chaos which
when my friend Rob Shaw was playing the
piano just now told me about immediately
connected to because but also I ended up
creating prediction programs based on
both of these principles the first
method was first principles it worked
very well
but it required a physicist to run and
we couldn't get enough physicists to
really like doing this kind of thing
professional gamblers I did it'd be a
method to buy then I actually I
shouldn't mention those other machines
actually had four kilobytes of memory I
mean that's four thousand bytes so it
didn't work very hard to write the
machine program that would actually put
put it into that memory to create an
operating system in a prediction
algorithm version - we actually had 64
thousand bytes by then and I could write
about her level language and including
routine was it was less accurate but
more robust because these gamblers could
actually adjust the parameters and make
it work okay now I'm going to inject
certain personal things in here to
illustrate this Punk race point about
the fortuitous phenomenon this is a
theme that will come through the lecture
making predictions can alter the future
after the book pneumonic Payan this was
published and data past the law gets
using computers to predict the outcome
of a game not just due to us all but
also due to some blackjack players they
were they were taking advantage of non
randomness and card shows the hot-plug
roulette wheel company designed a new
were left we would lower cups of more
elastic balls to enhance the chaotic
part winning players who placed bets at
the last minute or immediately has to
take their business elsewhere and and I
have to see it altered the rest of my
life why because prediction is a very
useful skill and once you learn how to
do it's like when I was in college I
knew how to fix motorcycles this was a
terrible thing because pretty soon
everybody I know who had a motorcycle
was showing up on my doorstep asking me
to fix their motorcycle now this had a
better effect than that next slide
please
this guy is partly responsible he's in
the audience here some night or tonight
his name's Tom Peterson the the fact
that I was doing that fact the fact that
I read I was reflecting on this that
story I told me last night by Isaac
Asimov was out of his book collection
which I would not have been exposed to
it if if he hadn't been a physics
professor at Western New Mexico
University now why would he have been a
physics professor at such a rinky-dink
school because well the story I won't
tell you here it's a fascinating story
but it involves Joe McCarthy
Frank Oppenheimer and his uncle who had
a gold mine in West Texas so because a
joke partly in his uncle okay I'm here
tonight talking about about this because
once I did roulette then everybody
always wanted me to you can't stay away
from prediction problems because because
it's too useful everybody keeps dragging
you back into it and and so anyway that
got me interested in all this stuff now
you're all here so we've all been
affected by go onto the next one
you know the the really hard prediction
next to the most really hard prediction
problems will get to the hardest ones in
a minute come when you have limits to
short term prediction and they come from
something called the curse of
dimensionality remember I mention this
idea of a state space which is how many
numbers do you have to have to predict
something now when that state space gets
big like when it takes say 50 numbers to
predict something's here the 50
dimensional state space then fitting
models to pass data empirically becomes
an extremely difficult task in fact you
now know about exponential functions
because it was in last night's lesson it
gets exponentially harder and this is
called the curse of dimensionality so
the amount of data you need gets
exponentially worse and if you have high
dimensionality plus chaos plus some
uncertainty inserted all in initial
conditions some systems just become
fundamentally unpredictable even for
very short times this was something this
cast of characters showed about 10 years
ago now so this is this is one of the
reasons the weather isn't hard just
because it's chaotic it's hard because
it's hard
and so it's very complicated
in the sense the economy is similar
except that the economy is even worse
because of this called market efficiency
as most economists believe the future
price movements are fundamentally
unpredictable and not just because of
this curse of dimensionality the problem
is if there are patterns in prices
profit-seeking behavior of participants
will eliminate them so that for example
if the price is gonna rise more people
will buy which drives the price up so
the price rise happens before anyone can
take advantage of it the comments don't
actually phrase it that way because they
don't liked it they don't think about
dynamics they just say it just happens
but I've actually built some models that
break it down and this is you see just
this kind of thing happening you see
these patterns evolving as the agents
evolve to take advantage of them so it's
another domain in which evolution plays
a very important role so the future is
in subset since pushed back to the
present now the result is unpredictable
arbitrage efficient prices that fully
reflect available information now what
this means is that you can't make money
by betting on the patterns that were
around now - first approximation this is
a good model and you know part of my
career pretty true company part had to
do with it really happened significantly
because of almost a dare trying
believing my brother-in-law cookie who
told me about this and I didn't believe
it and so I just decide you know the
only way you can really do it is to get
out there and actually showing works now
I want to emphasize that what production
company did and my pantheon of types of
prediction was empirical we have no
first principles model was a dynamical
prediction we were overtly trying to
predict the future and we were doing
this via on something that was
essentially very close to being
random process there was a little bit of
determinism but most of it was random
and of course we were trying to exploit
that little bit of determinism and we
managed money under exclusive
relationship with the United Bank of
Switzerland or Warburg Dylan read which
is a subsidiary thank you this is a
sellable or cerebellar approach to
market forecasting that is we
appearantly search for patterns and
historical data you know like it's not a
first principles model in other words
it's an app category the keys to making
work for feature extraction and the law
of large numbers that is like a feature
extraction if you look at how spider
monkeys actually see things that have
been a lot of experiments where people
put probes and spider monkey brains
famous experiments by Google in Diesel
true science a study doesn't what they
saw is if the spider monkeys don't just
directly process all the pixels in the
image and shove them in the middle of
their brain they they have detectors
that break down what's on the image so
for example you have moving shadows
bands like dark perspective between
their eyes their detectors to detect
each of these features that are features
that have evolved to be useful in their
world and only this much of pop more
high-level description goes deeper into
the brain to be processed and decoded
and that's really what we did most of
what prediction company researchers do
is find features like that so these all
involve prices we have little words
understanding the origin of the patterns
and we relied on the abundant past data
and stationary conditions the trading by
the way was fully automated so there
were no human decisions so we created a
kind of unconscious organism that could
process lots more data than a person
could process do so automatically make
trading decisions now okay here's the
Harvard Business Review view a religion
company as you can see there's a crystal
ball
pewter okay now this is just illustrate
the idea of efficient markets and why I
think it's important with on the other
hand one should not take it quite as
seriously as the economists equate
efficient markets were exactly right
that prediction company should never
have been able to stay in business now
this shows one of the signals the models
built out of multiple signals that in
some sense encapsulate different kinds
of information and it shows that back in
1975 the signal had about a 14 percent
correlation against a two-year that's
right at 2-2 we can have set of future
prices and we roll that along predicting
and the correlation drops and
correlation dropping just means the
predictions getting worse the
correlation goes to zero the predictions
worthless now you can see that this does
decrease through time so the market does
indeed seem to be efficient on the other
hand it takes 23 years for this decrease
to happen and this signal here it's
still tradable so somehow the economists
view is is right in principle but on a
much too slow a time scale now even more
puzzling to a mainstream economist is
this signal which actually grows through
time increases which according the
efficient market theory shouldn't happen
now what we think is that this is
because these patterns are driven by
human activity people with needs and the
market demanding things like like risk
reduction or liquidity and I'll explain
to you what that is in a little while
and so the need the demand for these
things was rising in the market was not
evil the our Treasuries were not not
able to track this very well no okay
let's go on to the next chapter the
direction of future prices is not the
only interesting aspect of a market
there other things that are also
important to understand like risk for
example people are very concerned about
the risk in their investments which is
awfully typically encompassed by
something called volatility I'll explain
in a moment or liquidity which is the
impact of trading on prices and
transaction costs as evidenced by the
bid-ask spread which is
it's between the buying price and the
selling price at any given moment now
these are nice to study as an academic
because they're not directly affected by
market efficiency so I'm like if you
came up with a better way to predict
prices and you published it in an
academic research journal and it really
worked well other people would go start
doing it and it would go away and
probably a lot faster than in that
twenty three year period that that
patterns probably hung around for 23
years because people have been fairly
secretive the top of what they do so
this is to illustrate what volatility is
here I show some hypothetical price
series and this is a low volatility
series the price moves randomly around
but it doesn't drip too much and down
here you can see the differences the
changes in price and you can see that
they're relatively smaller than over
here which is this example here where we
turned up the volatility and you see
that the price now drifts at a much
faster rate so this market is much
riskier than that market and you
generally people prefer less risky
markets they don't like to you know lose
their entire pension on fluctuation of
the market now this is an example of
liquidity I think I may have reversed
the slides you go one forward ok
liquidity is how much does price change
in response to a fluctuation in demand
or an order so if you come into the
market you say I want to buy a million
shares of XYZ calm you're gonna drive up
the price of XYZ calm and if you're
buying those shares because you want to
make profit on the price you want to
make profit on the price movements that
other people cause you're not going to
make any money from the one that you
caused so so that's what liquidity is
about this is this why you care about
liquidity now if this is closely related
to the slope of the supply and demand
functions that are famous in economics
okay go back so this is just an example
oh no I did have these in the white
where I apologize oh yeah excuse me I
have to go back and illustrate
volatility because this is
insolence measurement of volatility over
115 years span where the volatility is
measured in this case as the standard
deviation of daily prices and month
intervals plotted for each month now
what does that mean the standard
deviation is just how much did the price
vary during that month so go back and
slide again okay so this is a low
standard deviation and this is a high
standard deviation
okay forward forward right back to the
grid now I think I explained this
already so go on one more slide all
right yeah I want to put this in the
context of what perhaps the most
classical model in economic finance it's
a model by bachelier was created in 1900
and the model was that that prices
describe a random walk now - oh yeah he
actually came up with his model of five
years before Einstein came up with the
same model to describe Brownian motion
Einstein was probably unaware of that
shortly but but so this is a very old
well pedigree model now in such a model
the volatility of the physicists call it
the diffusion rate the rate at which
this jostling around happens is a
critical thing that you would like to
understand and one of the striking
things to be in economics is that there
really are no good ideas I would say
about what determines the volatility of
a random walk in crisis what is it about
on him that makes it be this volatile
whereas some other stock might be much
more volatile or much less horrible so
let's roll this light forward now how
would an economist approach this problem
- the economists would make it make an
assumption that there are agents spying
who act selfishly to maximize their own
utility utility just means their own
good I mean in the context of financial
markets it's typically just profits or
money though it might also involve
something about risk they might not like
risk so they like maximize their money
subject to the fact that they're scared
of risk the typical typical model
assumes perfect
reality or the typical neoclassical
model which dominated economics for the
last 20 or 30 years that's changing and
the basic program of economics now is to
take perfect for actuality and the other
perfect assumptions behind the standard
models and assume things like different
information so you go to the used-car
dealer used-car may really know a lot
more about the car that you do so
there's a symmetric information in the
bargaining process imperfect rationality
well we may not all be perfectly
rational at least the people that were
betting on that astrology scheme
institutional constraints there are a
lot of restrictions and markets that may
prevent markets from doing exactly what
they would do in the ideal case now the
typical economics model assumes that all
the agents take in this information they
take their model they value the prices
and the prices somehow come to the
collective valuation of the agents which
is always a it's a magic staff that I've
never liked in financial economics
models so gonna present an alternative
which is to look very carefully at the
mechanism for making trades in a real
market take the exact opposite
assumption and assume the agents
behavior is random and I think I think
of this as like designing a telephone
exchange you know every call every time
you make a call you presumably have a
perfectly good rational reason for
making that call but but the phone
company doesn't try and model telephone
calls by interviewing all its customers
and saying well now why do you make
telephone calls they they just they just
measure that there's a rate at which
people make calls that varies based on
the time of day it's assumed it's a
certain kind of random
process called a Poisson process and
they they then understand how if you
have you know tens of thousands of
agents following class honor processes
what the aggregate fluctuations are
going to be and they design an exchange
that can handle the calls most of the
time now we say this is a first
principles model and we're trying to
understand something about how the
market really works
it's a contemporaneous prediction which
is one of the reasons we don't have to
worry about market efficiency and it's a
random process model so that's how it
fits in my taxonomy of different
forecasting schemes next slide so what's
the development of the model first of
all begin with a simplest possible
random or replacement model also
designed to be simple to understand and
analyze then we'll modify the model
based on analysis of real data and then
we're going to evolve even more
sophisticated or more sophisticated
agents that that mimic the evolutionary
process in the market now let me say
that one of the surprising thing to us
is the simplest model actually worked
far better than we ever imagined it
could I want to introduce my
collaborators Julia yadi who's at King's
College London actually the physicist
who works in a finance department now
Eric Smith who's a postdoc at the Senate
the Institute Law School as you know mom
was a graduate student from Hungary
Supriya Krishnamurti a postdoc the
Senate the Institute where Chris Daniels
was the guy running the projector back
there provides all our computer
supported whole lot else the liaison
Paul graduate student from Croatia
Powell Italian graduate student from
Italy next slide so we're gonna analyze
what's called an order driven market
which is the way a modern market works
if you want to you know you decide you
want to buy IBM there's two basic ways
you can do it you call your broker and
you say I really want IBM right now
you've got to go get it for you like
this minute so you're broken we put a
market order that's it tells to you to
buy or sell a given number of shares at
the best available price at that time
and that's all you specify is how many
shares alternatively you can specify a
limit order which is buy or sell a given
number two shares at a specified price
it doesn't guarantee that you get
execution that is that you actually make
the trade because if the price doesn't
come to you your price is too low you're
being too ambitious well nobody will
take it now patient traders use limit
orders and impatient ones use market
orders so we now have a little animation
to illustrate this this picture by
orders are shown down here Silver's are
shown up here
prices are shown here and so really if
you're really chintzy you place your buy
order down here and just hope that the
price moves to you and you managed to
get out of the bargain so bargain
hunters live down here the ancients were
anxious people would put their orders up
here okay and what's called the best in
the best price being offered from the
point do the sellers similarly the
really chintzy sellers or patient
sellers put their orders up here and the
the more patient ones put them down here
and this height is the number of shares
of demand or supply this supply in this
case sitting at each price level in this
totally on the bottom it's a computer
that keeps track of all these words in
the old days people used to actually
write it down them now it's a computer
box and so just some more nomenclature
to spread this gap between the best best
buy spreads important because if you
immediately say buy then sell change
your mind and sell so if you buy you're
typically going to get a price that's
this if you come in as a buyer you'll
get this price coming as a celery and
you're you're well actually I'm getting
having the story here wait just a moment
so there's a best bid in the best house
all right let's yeah so let's show us
what happens with patient trading
patient really going to can you click so
we see new orders blowing into the
markets
so these are what we call non-marketable
limit orders that don't lead to an
immediate transaction we imagine them
raining onto the price axis from the top
and the bottom when you click again so
new new new new orders are just getting
added and and so this limit order book
is a storage device that's storing the
supply and demand okay now that's a
fairly special order because when that
came in we actually got that was a
better price to sell than anybody else
was offering before and so when that
happened the ass
the best ass got moved to a new value
okay is this clear to everybody all
right next slide right now suppose
you're impatient so when you're
impatient you submit a market order and
the market order has no limit price it's
just an organ system this is just just
give them to me I know I don't want to
wait around so I'm completely alright
there's the business now we depict the
market orders this big this big market
order coming in and now we're going to
see how that market order execute
against the existing limit orders and
creates trades every time it does so so
it's just a trade there with that guy
there's a trade there there's a trade
error there's another trade here and now
we just wiped out we just changed the
the new ask price again so we see how
the price moves as workers flow into the
market next slide now you have
intermediate patience you can do
something like a marketable limit order
where what you what you actually submit
a limit order but it crosses and we'll
see this cross series the bid the ask
here comes this marketable limit order
just let it sit as you can see it's a
price that's inside it's a buy order but
it's inside of the sellers it's above
the best ask so now what happens it
executes sequentially against all of
those leaving whatever's left over there
again moving the best ask all right now
in our model we well we make a
simplification that is we would treat
that actually as two events we treat
that as a market order that ate all that
stuff
by a limit order they got deposited
there but that's a decal next slide
the final thing you need to know about
is order cancellation that is people
sometimes to change their mind they go I
don't want to buy that anymore so click
and you stuff disappeared okay oh heck
try it again
okay you see some things disappeared
here order cancellation all right now
basic model so this is it's a very
simple model we just assume that
everything is random that the people
just randomly place orders so they they
place sell orders with some random
process and these arrows or to indicate
orders just raining down from the sky at
random and you'll notice that the seller
were the new sell limiters ring all the
way from the bid that is the best buy
price all the way up okay similarly the
the buy limit orders reign all the way
from the ask the the best best sell
price all the way down so that ass is
typically higher than the bid there's a
region where these are overlapping now
while we have market orders randomly
arriving and randomly canceling against
these these limit orders of the opposite
sign so close so by our market orders
flow in and cancel against sell limit
orders over here similarly sell market
orders flow in and cancel against buy
limit orders over here in addition we've
got this cancellation process now I
apologize for the Greek letters
physicists just can't help but use Greek
letters but so out that's the parameter
that describes limit orders you that
describes market orders and Delta that
describes cancellation and so what we're
interested in is understanding the depth
of the book at different times because
it turns out it tells us about those
other things like volatility liquidity
and and and a spread the spread you
already see how does it tell us about
volatility
well tells us about volatility because
as these orders arrive the price drifts
around we're showing it centered at zero
really the prices drifting randomly it's
making a random lock of some kind as
these orders arrive and the volatility
is determined by the rate at which that
price drifts the liquidity has to do
with how much depth there is an above
the books really deep there are lots of
people that want to sell and you want to
buy then you're not going to move the
price very much because there plenty of
buyers around if on the other end
there's very few then then the opposite
is true a big order like one we saw in
the picture will move the price a lot
next slide it's just an alternate
representation I don't I don't think I
need to show this one really now one of
the amazing things about this model is
that we've been able to use very simple
physics methods and actually some more
complicated physics methods too but
we've been able to use a lot of physics
methods to understand these very
fundamental quantities about the market
one of them so I won't describe most of
them but this one is so simple I'm gonna
try okay yeah of course everything's
hard to figure out and it you know
lecture where the lecturer gives you
three minutes and it speaks fast as I do
but okay this this is this is a
technique that's used all the time in
physics engine and engineering and
essentially has never been used in
economics and it's a way of guessing the
answers to things just by thinking about
their dimensions and the way they're
made up so for example suppose you want
to gas the formula for the period of a
pendulum so you first of all write down
all the things that could depend on well
what could it depend on it could depend
on the mass seems like an important
property of a pendulum or it could
depend on the length and it could depend
on gravity because it's gravity that's
actually pushing the pendulum back and
forth and leaves those are the things
that I can think of and so now what then
could the formula be well first thing
you'll notice is that mass doesn't
involve time length doesn't involve time
gravity does because gravity is an
acceleration of the acceleration of
gravity has units of length per time
squared that is it's the rate of change
of a velocity and a velocity is the rate
of change of position so rate of change
of position
as units of position or length over time
so the rate of change of velocity must
have units of length over time square so
so okay that's the only thing that has
time so that's got to be in the formula
but now time is on the bottom so we've
got to stick it on the bottom we got to
take one over little G okay 32 feet per
second per second and furthermore it's
squared so we've got to take a square
root now but we still don't have the
unit's right because this is there's a
length floating around it in G so if we
put we see that we put a link up here we
cancel the length in here and we get
something with units of time now one of
the striking things about this is they
just you doesn't point out that the mass
doesn't enter so I think that's kind of
surprising it seemed like the mass of
the pendulum would have mattered but it
doesn't you know Galileo interestingly
who deduced this formula and tested it
famously while in church watching the
chandeliers in the church swing and
taking his pulse which gives you a clue
why Galileo nearly got excommunicated
okay now fortunately we don't have to
face that kind of thing anymore just for
play football though actually we may get
excommunicated from the economics
community which does have a kind of
people aspect to it okay no no I'm not
going to go into too much detail about
this so don't get too scared yet but uh
but our model s five parameters I've
explained we have them up here
the other ones we didn't even quite
realise this white wave right away is a
typical order size which which has to do
with the kind of granularity of the
market it's kind of like a beach a beach
with big rocks on it is different than a
beach with really fine grains of sand so
this does turn out to be an important
parameter the other ones the tick size
and the tech size adjust prices move and
discrete increments they don't move
continuously there are quanta of prices
a physicist would say now in our world
the basic dimensions change we have
shares price of time so we still have
time but instead of say massive length
we have shares of price and and in the
next slide can see these parameters we
show their dimensions and I chose some
simple formulas the first three of which
we derived on the first two the first
three of which we derived by simply
juggling the combinations of these first
three parameters guessing its own out of
the first two weren't going to be as if
the last two weren't going to be as
important these were the combinations
that gave answers now we got the right
answers it turns out in these first
three this last one the answer that we
got by just doing this with these first
three parameters we immediately saw from
simulating wasn't right and we scratched
our heads and we realized that this
granularity has to be really important
and so we did some simulations we did
the simulations we came up with this
formula here so this formula comes out
the notice we have predictions for lots
of stuff we have predictions for the
slope of the depth near the origin which
is that's how fast is the is the depth
of sharez building up in the book that
has to do with liquidity with a spread
which has to do with a transaction cost
or buying and selling and with a
volatility which has to be with a rate
at which the price jitters around so
next slide now so these are the
techniques we've used it's long story
you know I mentioned confuse audiences
of physicists talk about all this stuff
and I confuse audiences of economists
even more because they've never heard of
any of this stuff but anyway we'll go
for the next slide and I'll spare you
guys that so we've actually been testing
these predictions now and here we see
this trading screen for the London Stock
Exchange so this represents the
electronic world that a trader and the
London Stock Exchange lives in and the
state of the market is changed every
time a trader pushes one of these
buttons one of these numbers will change
and the state of the market will change
as a result but I put it up because it
doesn't some sense give you an idea of
what the state of this of this world is
you can see there's lots of numbers
corresponding to the depths of training
as you go away there's historical
information you don't even know what's
on the screen next slide let me just say
okay actually so now what we're gonna
see is a movie and in this movie we're
going to see pictures just like the
pictures you were seeing before except
this is real data from the London Stock
Exchange for the company Vodafone over
some dates that I think will appear out
at the top when the movie start trying
so now what we see is as we go forward
in time we see these order is changing
in a limit order book as the as the
orders arrive now I think we're actually
skipping several frames at a time
run this you can see the time up there
so so and let's explain something else
the way we've displayed this the
midpoint price that is the middle of the
bitten the ask is actually fixed in the
middle of this movie so that's fixed and
the prices that it exists at the
boundaries of the movie are shown out
there at every instant of time and you
can see it's now April 13th 2000 its
9:06 and 907 and so anyway you just you
saw this kind of process unfolding the
bid me asks changing the depth is
changing transactions are being made
every time orders are placed or removed
in this in this book and you know
actually it's funny I'm not used to
looking at this at the speed because
normally when it runs it just blast a
day about I don't know 15 seconds or
something but if you aren't skilled of
looking at it I guess it's well it could
be a little incomprehensible anyway this
is a real market so on so let's go on to
the next slide so now now we're testing
on this data our predictions of the
spread which is this transaction between
it's the difference between the bitterly
asked turns out that when we do the
simulations we see that our we printed
this formula just for the dimensional
analysis the ratio of the market wear
rate to the limit order rate now
actually there's a small correction to
that that depends on some function of
this granularity parameter the typical
order size and then we divide it by
spite by the cancellation rate the
market order rate to make something
that's non dimensional physicists like
to do that because it gives you in some
way a cleaner way to see what's seeing
what's going on without being distracted
by kind of simple stuff now what we'll
see is that what we just well I'll show
you a prediction anyway a comparison of
a prediction computed using this formula
by measuring day by day for each stock
I'll start with a specific stock for
multiple stocks we measure what was the
average market order flow rate for that
day what was the average limit or
placement rate for that day what was the
cancellation rate for that day what was
the typical order size for that day so
we get a series of numbers for each day
we make a prediction for each day we
measure the same thing in the real data
and then we compare the prediction to
the real thing and let me emphasize
before I go forward that this is this is
the kind of a model that physicists
really like to make because it has no
free parameters that means that we've
set all the parameters up there in
advance
it actually physicists the way don't
like to make this kind of model because
it's very scary because when you make
the prediction you're really sticking
your neck out because you said this is
it we're not going to fit any any free
parameters to it I mean we just measure
these numbers make a prediction then we
go look at the quantity Marie you're
nodding your head what no no no the
function is a universal function that I
will show you a plot of in a moment okay
so function is fixed from the simulation
there's no parameter to the function
okay any other questions all right yeah
now so we see a comparison of our
prediction to the actual thing and so we
see there's some scam assist or Vodafone
there's scatter around this media's
predictions are not perfect but we
actually even though the simulation
they're not perfect because it's a
random process so there's random
variation that causes us to scatter at
the real simulation and the simulation
much less the real thing I have to say
when I saw this comparison I was I was
stunned because it's very rare that you
actually get to make a prediction like
this a priori go out and test it and
have it work so well these numbers over
here basically what they tell you is
about the slope of the fit the
parameters of the fit and so on we are a
little bit off of the slope to just
admit but that the linearity of this
plot comes out with a T statistic of 30
mm what does that mean it means it's
really good
okay now here is that function that
Marie was worried about that as I said
has no free parameters this function in
fact the first approximation you could
just take that function to be the number
point four five it does have a little
bit of variation and we do see that when
we put in that variation we get a little
better prediction now what surprised us
is this is that function of this is not
non-dimensional parameter I mentioned so
we're getting rid of the dependence of
the part we could we could describe from
dimensional analysis and what we see is
that the data even fits that part of the
prediction which we found I found ten
times as shocking as the first thing
which already found pretty shocking now
to go on one more step what we see is a
comparison of our prediction of
volatility which is described by this
somewhat more complicated formula up
here it involves more parameters that is
for one thing it involves this
cancellation rate in more there's a
stronger way it also involves this
granularity parameter the typical order
size of the stronger way so this
prediction tests a lot more about the
model furthermore you know the spread is
is what the economists call a micro
structured property it exists inside the
book it's it's not something that you
know you think about over time stands of
the year the volatility this is the
daily volatility the fact that exists on
daily volatility I'm now willing to bet
it's gonna work on weekly volatility
maybe monthly volatility we're really
starting to predict something about
about the properties of the market that
the economists won't just poopoo as
Michael structure and I should say only
some economists would do that was a
whole body of economists that work on
the microstructure but so the striking
thing you're against we get a straight
line this is a very fresh plot the scale
is off by about a factor of a hundred
and if I hadn't been preparing for these
lectures I would have been talking about
graduate students try and figure out why
this discrepancy exists but we're not so
worried about that because just getting
this but having the data roughly lined
up
like this is already a big result let me
mention this is not raw data anymore
these are been data so the data was been
and it's a groups of a hundred points or
so and so each of these represents the
average of a hundred points that have
nearby predictive values so this is
really exciting to us because economics
yes no no no it's a contemporaneous
prediction okay so what we do here is we
take a year and a half worth of Vodafone
data for each day we measure the those
those will investigates for parameters
in this formula which are order flow
rates and order sizes and then we also
independently measure how much the price
is moving around on that day okay and
then we we look at the actual is how
much the price moved around on that day
and the prediction is is as plotted here
and then we just plot we've been up to
predict the the points and then plot
them against each other okay it's a
contemporaneous prediction all right
anyway we're very excited by this
because I mean in economics is a field
where people just they're just really
aren't many models that where you make
you make a model of the model actually
puts the data in the style that models
fit or the data fits models and physics
in fact you know I've been looking into
this and I'm not sure there are any
models that work better than this in
terms of that criteria possibly the
black Scholes model for option pressing
ok next slide now what we're actually I
never I have to say I'm worried the
predictions that I showed you in the
previous they're almost too good that's
that's kind of a nice thing to worry
about normally you have to worry about
them not being
and work hard to make it better the
reason is because it's hard to believe
that random order flow is really the
whole story
I mean people aren't that stupid they
actually do do things that involve some
cognitive function that presumably got
something to do with setting prices and
so we're we're trying to improve it in a
couple of ways one way is to - we do
this demand for liquidity that acting is
a food for arbitrage ORS it's like an
ecology what do I mean there well well
liquidity is you want to buy or sell you
know your your mom gets sick you need to
raise some money to pay the bills you
want to buy some sell some of your stock
you I can't say I want to sell it and
you know you're not gearing off you
don't have some rational model about
prices it's one cash so that's what what
what economists would call a liquidity
demand er and in our model all the
marketer traders are just liquidity
demanders they demand liquidity for
random reasons and and the limit order
guys are actually feeding off of those
guys but they're feeding off of them in
a particularly dumb way that is randomly
placing women workers so we're trying to
make this world a little more realistic
by actually having the Predators in this
artificial college without our real
ecology just a market ecology making
some models for the kind of predators
that are actually out there you know the
Tigers and and so on and so what kind of
such predators a market maker another
kind is somebody who explores an order
of balance I'll show you the example a
minute other kinds of technical trader
that's like the guy went up there
Bonacci numbers though actually he's got
other stuff in there and let me say when
you add in these guys well actually I'll
come back to that other bullet let's
show the next slide so this is a
collaborator for the next slide I'm
gonna show Jim Rhon who's spending the
year at the Institute of doing science
as a hobby after
something oh and some big tech company
all right so this is his view of the
ancient ecosystem that he's got this
market maker agent books you've got
different agents the agents are
interacting with each other they're
feeding off of the on the liquidity
demanders and they are themselves about
Co evolving with each other has this
goes along another picture I'll show we
don't have this guy we just have this
guy then what this guy does
excuse me it's look to see whether
there's an order imbalance in the book
if there's lots of buy orders sitting in
the book and not too many sell orders
then he goes oh okay I know that future
order flow is random there's lots of
borrowers and if the orders hit there
they're not going to move the price very
much there's a wall set up by all those
borrowers that keeps the price from
going down too much seller is on the
other hand there's not too many though
so same level of orders they're going to
roll right through there and really make
the price move so the price is likely to
go up so this guy plays that strategy
next slide what we see here is a
comparison of the spread that exists
without this agent and the spread that
exists with that agent in America where
we include that agents market order flow
in the soup and explain again what the
agent does does the agent says okay
there's lots of buyers all put in a bar
a by market order so that I myself and
it'll hold it for a while until I
hopefully realize the price going up and
I sell it again that's what this guys
doing you see in this picture is that he
is she is altering the price here the
spread but I may be you know 50 percent
or something
to make money the way you make money is
you you buy low you see the sort of
balanced build up you you buy right then
and when the price is where it is and
then you at this point have a
conditional forecast given this
situation the price is likely to go up
so you hang on to it for a while and
then you sell it again and if and the
strategy means you could see that I mean
actually I tossed out this slide showing
the guy's profits but he actually
reaches a peak in its profits around
this point because indeed the market
does tend to go up when there's far more
buy limit orders there's far more stored
demand than there is stored supply clear
okay there's no profit on the ground
I should okay
now actually well let me just let's go
back just let me talk about this a
little bit so we're actually bothered
that our predictions are so good because
we really would have thought as we add
in this ecology that things would shift
out there could be as we really build up
a more mature college with all of the
niches filled we push ourselves
something back into a world that's much
more like the random world okay but
we'll see this is an experiment in
progress
next slide all right so we're also doing
other things we're looking at various
effects measuring things for the data to
make the model more realistic to to
certain kind of empirically look at what
real agents do agents don't place the
orders the way
showed you we actually know how they do
that now and we know that there are
correlations in their performance that
they're doing one thing they tend to be
doing that thing 10 minutes later
they're also her feedback effects the
agents are responding to the price of as
an interplay between the price and in
fact that gives bursts of volatility and
lots of stuff by the interest of trying
to get you guys out of here on time I
tossed all those slides out so let's go
forward all right I just want the slides
one thing though which is kind of
surprising that is that is part of what
we're doing this different from the way
economists look at what we say look
there's a new year market see the story
demand demand is not a static thing like
you learn about it in the economics book
it's something that flows like water and
and you need to store demand in order to
facilitate transactions the lipid order
book is just a storage device like it
has persistent states it's like a
reservoir I mean you take a reservoir
you breach the dam the water isn't
instantaneously in the Pacific it takes
time to flow out and we're an electrical
capacitor is another good example except
it's more complicated because you've
gotta buy and sell and there's really
two different reservoirs and they're
interacting with each other but but we
really think of this in a very physical
way now one of the the paradoxical
things about this city when we put in
random order flow we get a non-random
pricing behavior and our hypothesis is
that is we have more intelligent agents
they will make the order flow less
random but the price is more random but
but this idea that completely random
behavior actually results in non-random
the output is something that I think is
a little surprising to us this next line
all right the conclusions with this part
and then I'll go into the next part
which is a lot shorter is it up market
institutions are important a detailed
mechanistic model of how trading happens
to have substantial predictive element
to tie in with a theme in my first
lecture you notice how mechanistic it is
I mean there's like little atoms
bouncing into each other it's a very I
think mechanistic view of what goes on
the market and for some purposes
randomness maybe a little maybe a better
model than rationality and so we're
taking the current the current approach
in economics and program and turning it
upside down instead of starting with
rationality and detuning it we're
starting with randomness and throwing in
a little bit of rationality so on next
slide now to transition this is actually
another prediction of our model that
we're trying to test we don't know yet
how well that really works let me just
explain it is because it ties into this
next theme which is that trading
influences prices so predictions affect
the world and this is showing some
curves
it'll assume a as you trade more shares
how the amount you effect affects the
world next slide with okay you don't
need to know that details is that we
show up right of examples here let me
just say that where do we we're trying
to test against these examples
qualitatively it looks pretty good we do
see curves that are much flatter than
economists would have predicted that are
sloping this way they're getting flatter
as you go up rather than getting steeper
everybody used to think they must get
steeper and steeper as you go up so this
results are already seeming to fit
but let's go on to the next topic okay
this can't be the whole story I mean
what about psychology so we're feeling a
lot of timescales human psychology must
be important
one short term it seems the price
behavior is random but over sufficiently
long term prices have to be more
rational but seem to be universal
patterns of human behavior such as
speculative bubbles that play themselves
out again and again with human
psychology where reality influences
perception and
influences reality there's a feedback
loop so next slide this is a familiar
recent example announcer we see there's
been a big price bubble prices went up
but a huge factor and then dropped again
for what seemed to be no apparent
economic reasons next slide this is just
a longer-term view of the same thing
show the big build-up to the bubble the
bubble popping and dropping back down
again now for for those people that were
thinking about bubbles going through
this it seemed a little bizarre when we
were up here which is kind of hard to
believe because you know it's this is
this is a mistake that people have made
over and over and over again there's a
1980 book by Charles Mackay called
popular delusions of the madness of
crowd crowds where he details all sorts
of of price bubbles and going forward
this is for example the price of wheat
in Munich in the early 1800s you see a
similar kind of bubble next slide
price of wheat in Paris of the centuries
before I could you know pull out a
gallery of fifty or a hundred of these
things and of course the problem is is
it's always tempting to hang on here and
it's very hard to predict when this
parts going to happen so I showed
bananas just because bananas seemed
about to be about the only thing
that don't show bubbles so people
actually think maybe this is because
bananas can't be stored very long and to
really get a bubble going you have to be
able to speculate the speculate you have
to be able to store it but so it's it's
really seems to be speculation that
drives these bubbles and not just of
course bubbles can also be fueled by a
massive light but more generally they're
just fueled by by greed next slide now
this is just illustrate where they say
before about on a long enough time scale
there two slides here I won't see much
about where it comes from but the dot is
some economist idea of a rational
valuation of the American stock market
at different times and the solid line is
the price spotted logarithmic scale so
everything's compressed these are
actually much bigger swings than you see
with your eye and what you can see is
prices could spend decades out of line
with values at least according to this
valuation formula now people is that a
lot of trying time trying to find
valuation formulas it better and so far
have not had much success but so I'm not
saying that our model describes prices
over five year time spans over long
enough times I think you see that prices
do indeed tend to revert to values but
it takes you know five years to decades
for that to happen but over shorter time
spans like a day certainly and possibly
even we think a month or up to a year
prices just seem to be random because
well I don't think people can predict
them very well next all right so
so this is the last little chapter of my
talk the fortune-teller problem I want
to focus in a little bit more on pardon
me
certainly can you yell yes you mean
these of the Armada what insider-trading
felt older-model I just described off or
are there ways in Jekyll to identify
insider trading because certainly the
SEC spends a lot of time looking at
looking at various things that that
allowed that give them clues about when
people are doing insider trading now
these are the our model at their insider
traders would that make our model that
less well I kind of got it actually but
I don't know yeah no well our model is
not particularly important about that
okay so a lot of the next part of this
we don't have to find something in my
notes here okay so now I want to talk
about the fortune-teller problem that is
the predicting the future influences the
future and in particular thinking about
two kinds of forecasts one is an
absolute kind of forecast I predict that
X will happen the other is a contingent
forecast which is if you do X if you do
Y X will happen so they're different and
you know obviously there's another kind
of forecast in general is safer but and
an economist economic model is generally
made contingent forecasts and then try
and turn those eventually into absolute
forecasts but but let me just say the
influence is weaker for continuous
contingent forecasts but the effect is
still president now to get you the idea
of the fortune-teller problem I want to
read you a quote
the crossing by Cormac MacCarthy if a
dream can tell the future it can also
afford that future for God will not
permit that we shall know what is to
come he is bound to no one that the
world shall unfold just so upon its
course and those who by some sorcery or
by some dream might come to pierce the
veil that lies so darkly over all that
is before them may serve by just that
vision to cause that God should wrench
the world from its heading and set it
upon another course all together and
then where stands the dreamer where
stands the sorcerer where the dreamer
and his dream
Oh kind of a public forum to have your
fortune told
I see that you will be taking a trip
true where well kids II can't imagine
why I go to Poughkeepsie New York but
well is it a good trip
no no no a train wreck
oh that doesn't sound good
my dad Lee heard a compound fracture of
the tibia near the patella just just out
of curiosity I mean is it possible that
I don't go and and if I don't go well
there's still be a train wreck probably
other people get hurt too
I should probably avoid I should
probably avoid that one well well so
what happens if I don't go to
Poughkeepsie
and you get very bored well sounds
sounds better than even a compound
fracture you contract a fatal disease
oh well that actually the fatal that
sounds worse than the tibia yeah then
maybe for you I haven't told you what
happens to all of the other people on
the train okay well okay so you're
saying they get rid of it worse like I
can't get out of this by just choosing
the train instead of staying home so
well well suppose I take a different
trip where do I go where do you want to
go you're supposed to be a gypsy you're
supposed to be a gypsy and now you're
talking in terms of a probability
that doesn't sound too bad out of me you
know all things given here still you
know I'm kind of worried about the 1.3%
wait wait a minute wait a minute though
you're supposed to be a gypsy I mean
you're supposed to look in that crystal
ball and see my fate I mean you're
supposed to see my one true fate instead
you're talking about you're talking
about numbers and probabilities and all
this stuff I mean I mean gypsies don't
do that what about what about Oedipus I
mean Oedipus Oedipus you know he tried
it everything is good good to avoid his
fate he he couldn't it happen no matter
what no matter what he tried to do he he
couldn't avoid it so what happened to my
one true unavoidable
how do you feel about her anymore
I have no problem do you need a psychic
or a psychiatrist I'm just fine I don't
need a sec okay okay forget about all
that let's get back to this faith thing
okay now have you ever heard of chaos
theory where do you think free will
comes from anyway the future it's not
completely deterministic the slightest
alteration can change everything
there are a billion tiny little
possibilities that can create new future
and scatter your faith to revenge the
prediction is part of the system see it
changes the initial condition and these
changes change the initial conditions
and on and on and off to infinity there
is an exponentially growing number of
possibilities you ask me these stupid
questions about your vacation I can
promise you it's too much to track with
my crystal ball why don't you ask me
something easier like tomorrow's weather
or where to bet on the rule at Vail
well because I don't want to know about
roulette or the weather you know I want
to know about my vacation like like I
don't know you know how did how do the
flight schedules to to go see a travel
agent
he said you think she was Mickey wait
something a little weird going on here
laptop so the fortune teller problem you
can see have a problem with fortune
tellers here Oh buddy we put on put on
the next slide
oh yes I'm sorry this was the one with
core max thing all right no well I guess
you'll have to suffer with my reading of
court but but is what's the slide after
this these are my nope
back Marcus all right we'll start here
okay I wanted to put oh there it is
core max words that was what was
supposed to be up well you realistically
though gypsy just so you have case you
were bored by Olivia which I could
imagine would be anyway I like these
words though you know I have to say Mike
my son Eli had written this and showed
it to me I would have made a put a few
comments in there but
and not karnak so just shows it was
right now anybody going no I'm just
kidding next slide
all right now what I'm about to do is
show you a little model that we made up
for feedback between perception and
reality so the idea is that some it's a
sports betting game an idealized sports
betting game so for example you have n
agents and these n agents bet on some
event at time t like horse race and the
odds are based on a net wager on each
outcome that is if a lot of people bet
on that horse that horse isn't going to
pay off very good odds almost no one
bets the odds become really good if you
win now we the difference between what
we're going to do here in the normal
standard model is that we're going to
allow for the possibility the outcome is
influenced by the odds financial markets
provide a good example because because
well supply and demand particularly
demand are inherently subjective things
they're determined by human preferences
and privacy prices move in response to
those preferences and whether you win or
lose your bet depends on on that
psychologically driven thing which in
turn can alter reality because for
example if the price of something goes
up then investment capital goes up then
widgets of the type that those guys want
to build get built and if the opposite
happens the price goes down in those
widgets don't get built so there's this
feedback between our perceptions of
reality and what reality really does the
simplest case well so for this model
back to this model that we're going to
reduce it to just a coin flip so we
imagine there's a coin so there's only
two outcomes but we'll let the coin
respond to the odds on heads versus
tails it's like a a jockey that's
responding to the odds because if the
odds get too good you might decide to
throw the race except in this case it's
just it's like a smart coin so now I'm
gonna show next slide these are my
collaborators on this project Seth Lloyd
was a professor of mechanical
engineering at MIT and Jonathan Kohler
was an undergraduate there next slide
Marcus we need to see the maps before
this picture here no it depends on that
okay yeah good so this is what an
objective coin would be like this would
be a coin that's unaffected by the odds
so the idea here is that the subjective
bias is the net that's how much people
bet on heads over here versus tails over
here and if half the people bet on heads
and half bet on tails then the
subjective bias is in the middle if more
people bet on heads it starts to move
over this direction now this is the real
bias the objective bias this is what the
coin really does as you can see in this
case the coin is always a fair coin it
always stays at 50/50 for heads or tails
next slide now this is the coin that's
like an efficient market and that what
happens in this case is as more people
bet on heads the payoff to heads the
probability that heads comes up goes
down so the coin gets biased
in such a way as to forward its future
as in core max quote now I've sketched
in this identity line just to show you
that what I'm going to do if you think
of this map happening the point that
remains invariant is the 50/50 point for
an unbiased coin so if you imagine that
what we're going to do is we're gonna
explore cases where we start out with an
objective coin and then we're gonna play
it around with a map between the odds
and reality we're gonna leave this point
here invariant so that if if reality is
if this feedback loop between reality
and perception is stable
everything will stick at this point but
if that feedback loop isn't stable it'll
blow away and go somewhere else so next
slide okay so this is an example of a
positive feedback world where as the
subjective bias increases actually the
identity line would already be an
example of this where as the probability
of betting on heads increases sorry as
more people bet on heads the coin
becomes biased towards heads the
identity line would do that this curve
also does does this it turns out
this is fresh work and I should probably
have a few more explanatory slides but
we were able to prove that under some
cases this point is a Nash equilibrium
so a lot of you probably saw a beautiful
mind and I think they mumbled one little
line about what that wasn't there what
it means is that is that the Nash
equilibrium
it's the player it's the place where you
can defend your bet in the sense that
somebody playing your same strategy
against you can't beat you and in the
case that we see here that Nash
equilibrium becomes destabilized so now
Marcus if we could show those those
color pictures that you were about to
flash on now I have to admit that we
were frantically graphing these today
and I haven't even seen them so on what
we have here and remind you well Marcus
left the screen from the booth Lebaran
if time is going to going this way
Marcus this way yeah and so the the
different agents are going this way
ranging from the agents that are betting
entirely on tails to entirely on hats
and the amount of space they take up
represents how much of the money they
have at this time so what you can see is
in this world this orange guy and this
guy here end up splitting all the money
at the end of the run and they're both
coming from around here somewhere so
they both come out of roughly the same
probability actually let me we could
read it off okay well I don't quite see
the code yeah there they are so these
are guys that are both making bets that
are very close to to all tails tails
tails as you recall that went into the
probability spectrum that is this is an
unstable world in which the the feedback
was positive if you start to bet on
heads heads gets more likely and it's so
strong that you blast off - just pegging
the coin on to heads or maybe it's tails
just you peg it on tip and in fact in
these kind of worlds one of the things
you see is that the final outcome is
indeterminate the first few coin flip
flips determine which way you go if the
first few coin flips happen to Fay
the guys that are betting on tails then
they start to grab all the money they
bet on tails even more which weights the
odds toward tails which then causes the
coin to become more likely to make tails
which then gives those guys even more
money on average and so it just goes off
and the coin that is reality collapses
in this kind of a picture and we can
we're really Marcus you want to play
another one do you have another one of
those or is that the only one that's the
only one it doesn't really know I mean
access to what we see actually satisfies
our predictions and and which is that
that the coin will actually tolerate a
certain amount of positive feedback that
is this feedback between betting on
heads and having the coin be more likely
for heads we can tolerate a certain
amount of that and keep the reality of
the coin being unbiased stable but if we
turn that up too much there's a critical
point where everything collapses and the
coin turns into a completely biased coin
that either bets on on but always comes
up heads or always comes up tails
because that's what people perceive that
it's going to do now
so then summarize this part if you're
able to create reality it becomes
difficult to know well this is maybe
going beyond it not summarizing what
reality even is that is in a world we
are making predictions and you're
altering the world around you in if you
think about you know our world is
increasingly artificial more horrible if
as you go through your day ask yourself
how many of the things I'm saying around
me are artifacts how many are
artificially created objects how much of
my environment is being artificially
controlled and how much time do I spend
on object around in a material world
that is unaffected by human behavior the
answer is is what's really the answer is
none because we're affecting everything
on the globe right now but but as our
world becomes more artificial and as we
create the world more and more in the
essence of what we desire that's like
saying if I want I want the coin to be
heads and
I'm gonna bet on heads if if that
feedback becomes positive there's danger
of that reality becoming unstable
because there's these feedback loops
between our predictions of the world are
our desires our predictions of the world
what we create and and and what our
desires are now these feedback loops can
vastly complicate the dynamics in a
world where you're affecting the world
all the time you have to make yourself
part of the prediction in an economic
world where you're affecting prices you
have to factor that into your model and
that vastly complicates the modeling
process that creates it I believe what
could be called a danger of a kind of
societal schizophrenia where we lose
track of in a sense what reality is and
what we want next slide I just want to
show you know very familiar example
everybody this is the temperature of the
earth this is from the recent study by
the National Academy of Science this is
the temperature of the earth is best
estimated over the last millennium and
you can see the temperature moves in a
complicated way and then there's a
sudden rise now it's been very difficult
to untangle whether this sudden rise is
human caused or not we know we're
affecting the world we have to model we
have to have a good model of the world
in order to unravel that and we have to
be able to separate out the already
substantial natural variation that's
going about on back here
from whatever artificial variation we
might be imposing here one thing we do
know that we're changing in a major way
is next slide this is the co2 level over
a similar period it's risen dramatically
in the last couple of centuries and and
we know that that change is caused by
human behavior and we know that co2 has
a big effect on temperature and the rest
of the planet we don't know exactly what
that effect effect is so we're dealing
with a situation where where this
feedback is is because the feedback
involves what is it I mean and to engage
in the purposeful behavior that we like
to engage in to do things like have
automobiles to
manipulate our worlds to to suit
ar-ar-ar-ar needs of well in the long
run I propagation writ large of society
well I'll come back into that doctor
more in the final lecture but but to
satisfy our perceived needs we're making
a big change in our world we're trying
to forecast what that change is and the
huge uncertainties and the forecasts are
generating huge risk that we may destroy
the very thing that we like so much now
or at least change in a radical way that
may not be advantageous to us and
certainly may not be advantageous to uh
so let me just summarize the evenings
lecture predictions a key element of
purposeful behavior coming out of
propagation
I haven't actually talked about that so
much I'll admit I did somewhat shoehorn
this lecture into the fact that I really
wanted to talk about prediction but but
I've tried to illustrate the different
ways of making predictions and and give
you some flavor for the the kind of the
form those kind of predictions take and
the kind of things they can do and this
is the last point I was making that as
the sophistications of predictions
increases the effect on the environment
can make prediction more more difficult
and for humans created a danger of
social schizophrenias like market manias
thank you
I have to apologize it realize I went
even longer tonight sorry about that
tomorrow night I'll try the third time
by the way there'll be questions in a
minute as soon as people get I work hard
to prepare the lecture down time myself
beforehand it timed in at about a minute
15 1 hour and 15 minutes and I would not
want to take the responsibility for your
buying and selling I am NOT I am
certainly not buying well if you believe
the Modern Portfolio theory then you
should just go buy something that
simulates the s P and X are better
diversification get some kind of World
Index that combined stocks and bonds and
lots of other things if you believe that
theories which which I don't but but you
know I will say that for most people I
think is pretty dangerous to go out and
play the market I mean I I don't you
know the market house is full of
surprises and what prediction company
did is one of those don't try this at
home the kind of things you know it
involved staffed with with you know 10
or 20 people to begin with and lots of
computer equipment and lots of PhDs and
so on
you know it's a reasonable thing to do
yeah you know that I don't the computer
does it I don't even you know I don't
even know what's up or down on you today
let's take questions that don't involve
financial advice oh yes we do have a few
papers out there are fairly technical
papers where the process of writing a
paper there will be more further well it
will be over the article it still won't
be a general public they look it's
probably gonna be a while before we
write it more a general public oriented
piece on this yeah you can get you can
you can come to you can look at my
website for example we posted I post the
papers there as soon as they're done so
it's it's you go to the stamp a website
just look through some people and you
can find my website easily yes
what happens in body
yeah in some cases there may be I mean
the market itself if you want to think
about it in terms of turbulence it's
very developed high Reynolds number
turbulence it's not anywhere near the
transition and and and give it's worse
as I said because of this feedback
through the efficient market now it is
true that in some situations like like
well in that model that I was showing
for the feedback between subjective and
objective reality betting ad there are
certain critical points where the
behavior dramatically changes and you go
from nice stable behavior to behavior
that's sensitively dependent on the
fluctuations that happen at the
beginning so so yes there are some
analogies but you know analogies are
wool
speak up Oh I mean the model the model
that they don't know when you say models
which ones do me I'm not engaging that
way now though actually there is an
effort that may be starting up a testify
to try and synthesize people who are
working in different areas relating to
problems of the political economic
ecological problems try to synthesize
those views together and I hope to be
involved in that project you know I
don't think the models that I gave here
bear on this favorite question very
directly although I do think that it is
socially if with the deep we can predict
volatility and give insight and about
into what causes volatility we can then
give insight into how designed markets
to decrease volatility which I think
most people would be view is a very good
thing and so I do think there maybe I
can even from something as simple as
that
let me see if I understand your
questions the question is in the model
is there some ratio of market order at
limit order placement that makes things
unstable well the answer is that's
actually one of the reasons why it's so
critical to have the order cancellation
process in the model because if nobody
ever cancels an order and more people
are placing say limit orders that market
orders then the order just build up and
build up and build up without down I'm
sure the pricing would never move into
our conversely if more market orders are
being placed as limit orders then the
book is basically always almost flat the
market's extremely volatile you put in
this cancellation process it means that
even without the market orders the limit
order the depth in the market builds up
to some sensible place so that you get
sensible responses to prices and so the
answer is if you take Delta to 0 you do
get an instability understand pretty
thing when you have extreme imbalances
of either one I don't know if that's
what you were asking for
our bubbles in financial markets
contemporaries yeah well yeah I mean I
sure felt in 1998 like lots of people
lots of people do the problem is there's
no like there's no stone tablet that
says we are in a bubble and if you read
the paper around that period there were
plenty of people you know helium suckers
who were markets and you know there were
a new world and you know what amazing
things that you go back to the record
and almost every bubble there's a crowd
of people saying this world is different
from the old world it's a new regime
it's a whole new kind of industry it's
going to change things in the
fundamental way and so yes I think there
are a lot of signs here in bubbles and
maybe it will be that we will someday
get more astute about this and and so
bubbles will diminish and one of the
problems in my view is that mainstream
economists do not actually try to build
models that predict bubbles because
because think about what you have to do
that you have to have some kind of model
of psychology and that's only recently
become fashionable in economics you have
to have a model that involves dynamics
and get captures as feedback
and there's a lot of stuff that
economists just think they don't like
those words you know you start saying
those kind of things to them that they
just edge away from you and say sorry
they're not viewed as acceptable ideas
in modern economics you have a very hard
time fitting models like that publish to
face very little effort going into some
of them such models which is a pity
because it seems like
you